hey this is kim from khan academy and
today i'm learning about article one of
the us constitution article one is
jam-packed with information about how
our government is supposed to work but
principally what it does is create the
legislative branch of government which
includes the house of representatives
and the senate which together comprise
the congress of the united states
article 1 also tells us how people can
get elected to those bodies and what
powers congress has to learn more about
article 1 i talked to two constitutional
experts ilia selman is a professor of
law at the antonin scalia law school at
george mason university whose research
focuses on constitutional law property
law and the study of popular political
participation professor heather gerkin
is the dean of yale law school she's a
leading expert on constitutional law and
election law and her research focuses on
federalism diversity and dissent
article one gives an enormous amount of
power to the legislative branch
otherwise known as congress and it was
designed specifically to overcome some
of the problems that they'd seen under
the articles of confederation the
legislative power under the artistic
confederation was pretty weak uh in part
because
the uh the congress under the
confederate articles didn't have the
authority to directly tax the states
they also
lacked a lot of other powers that
were eventually given to congress under
the constitution these were the things
that really mattered if you're building
a young nation you need to be able to do
certain things in order to protect it
especially at that time when there were
many many other countries that were
circling around wanting to grab land and
power and so the united states needed to
defend itself in those early days okay
so we all know today that our
legislative branch is made up of the
senate and the house of representatives
but it didn't have to be that way so why
was it that the framers settled on this
two-house structure for the legislative
branch
i think for several reasons one is that
it was a compromise between the small
states and the large states uh the large
states the ones that have a lot of
population
wanted representation in congress in
accordance with population obviously
then the large states would get more
representatives the small states on the
other hand were concerned that they
would be dominated by the large states
if that happened so in the end the
compromise is you have one house the
house of representatives which is
largely apportioned based on population
uh and one house the senate uh which is
a portion
based on each state having uh two votes
no matter how small or how large it is
a second reason why you end up with the
structure is the influence of the
british example the british had both the
house of commons and the house of lords
uh and the house of commons of course
being more subject to popular pressure
uh while the house of lords were the
seaweed aristocracy uh and the founders
also wanted a combination of popular and
elite power and it was thought that the
senate would fill that elite role in
part because initially the senators were
chosen by state legislatures rather than
by the voters directly so the house of
representatives which is based on
districts is supposed to represent you
based on where you live
and the senate which is based on states
is supposed to allow at that time the
state legislature to nominate two
luminaries from the state to represent
the state so yeah for a long time the
the senators were actually appointed now
they're elected senators were appointed
until the passage of the 17th amendment
which amended article 1 and that gave
state legislatures a fair amount of
influence over who went to the national
government but it is also true that many
states by that time already effectively
had popular election of senators
really interesting okay so you describe
the senate as being kind of the american
version of the house of lords a little
bit more elite a little less
subject to popular opinion how does that
carry over into the senate that we have
today how are its powers different from
the house of representatives
it does have certainly different powers
from the house in some respects for
example it has the power to ratify
treaties and to confirm appointments to
the court into the president's cabinet
so
earlier this year when neil gorsuch was
appointed to the supreme court he had to
be confirmed by the senate obviously
today the senators are elected
just like members to house are and i
think they're every bit as partisan and
almost as sensitive to public opinion uh
as members of the house of
representatives
so the difference between the senate and
the house in that regard
maybe it hasn't completely disappeared
but it's certainly greatly diminished
okay so there are certain powers that
are reserved to the senate are there
particular powers that are reserved to
the house of representatives the house
is important you don't underestimate the
importance of the house i'll just say uh
the house of representatives for example
is allowed to initiate impeachment
proceedings against the president uh if
the house votes in favor of impeachment
then
the senate holds a trial to determine
whether the official in question gets
convicted or not as a general matter
though they're roughly co-equal for the
big important things like passing
legislation you need both of them to
work together
so together these two houses make up
congress so how is congress different
from the executive branch or the
judicial branch what are what are its
powers
the way that the framers understood it
was that each one would have their own
job so the judiciary obviously was there
to judge disputes between people to run
the court system etc the executive was
there to carry out the laws and so the
executive's job is to administer the law
once it has been made
and of course the legislature is there
to legislate so its main job was to make
the law and at the time i will just tell
you everyone thought that the big
gorilla in the room was congress that it
would be by far the most powerful
organization the framers simply did not
anticipate how powerful both the
judiciary and the president would become
over time so what happens if for example
the congress and the president don't get
along
well it happens quite a lot
the president could refuse
to
uh uh to accept laws passed by congress
he can veto them uh in that event uh
congress could only override it if
two-thirds of both the house and the
senate voted to do so
congress on the other hand can pressure
the president in various ways they can
hold hearings investigating his conduct
of various issues
they can defund agencies
of the executive branch whose job
performance they don't like they can
refuse to confirm the president's
appointees to various offices and in
extreme cases that have happened a
couple of times in our history congress
can even impeach the president and if he
gets convicted in the senate then he
would be removed
from office this is what led to the
resignation of richard nixon the house
of representatives impeached him
and nixon resigned before he could be
tried in the senate uh president andrew
johnson and president bill clinton were
also both impeached uh and in both cases
the senate ultimately acquitted them uh
but uh it was still a very painful time
for both of those presidents
so speaking of antagonistic
relationships i think one thing that's
really come to dominate congress is
partisanship to what extent did the
constitution anticipate this rise of
parties and partisanship uh they
actually knew about parties to some
degree from the british experience uh
but they were very suspicious of them
and they hoped and perhaps expected that
they wouldn't emerge in america to
anything like the same extent that they
had in britain but in actual fact within
a few years after the adoption of the
constitution we already had the first
party system the federalists and the
democratic republicans and partisan
alignments have played a big role in
congress ever since then so even back
then there were rival interpretations of
how the constitution should be carried
out and what kind of power the national
government should wield but they somehow
thought naively i think that the parties
would disappear and that people would
have allegiances to their state or to
their region but they wouldn't be uh
have allegiance to a party that that
broke down completely almost immediately
after the constitution was written that
leads to a real problem these days
because most modern constitutions
recognize that there will be two parties
that they will be in competition with
one another and that part of the job of
the constitution is to regulate that
competition
would the founders have done anything
differently you know if they had known
about parties and expected that they
would play such a big role it's hard to
know for sure but maybe they would have
been less confident uh than some of them
were that congress would always stand up
for its prerogatives against the
president
when the president and congress are of
the same party
i think often uh congress is inclined to
overlook various presidential abuses
if the reverse is true things might be
very difficult to do
exactly i mean the whole point about
them needing to act um needing one
another to act is really a problem if
one side is antagonistic to the other
side
one other thing we see here in article
one is is talking about kind of what the
federal government does versus what the
states do so this is kind of the the
idea of federalism then could you tell
us a little bit more just about what
federalism is and how it's supposed to
work
so the way that we understand federalism
back then
was that there was a division of labor
the states would regulate things that
were inside their territories and
accorded to them in terms of
responsibility and the federal
government would regulate
everything that was accorded to it under
the constitution the problem is
as congress's power became more and more
expansive it ended up regulating the
same areas that the states regulate
so if the federal government and the
states have a law on the same topic who
wins
as long as it's passed properly by the
federal government the federal
government wins so if there is a federal
law and the state law is inconsistent
with it the state law is displaced
is there anything that might surprise
the framers about how our congress
operates today
uh when uh the framers created article
one and drafted it they certainly
expected that congress would have more
power uh under the constitution than it
did under the articles of confederation
uh but i don't think very many of them
would have believed that congress would
ever be able to do things like forbid
the growth of medical marijuana in your
backyard uh or regulate what kind of
toilet you're allowed to have in your
house
uh or
for that matter do something like the
war on drugs which forbids the
possession of drugs
throughout the country and uh the like
originally the power to regulate
interstate commerce
which is the authority under which most
of these things are done it was
at the time conceived of as a power for
congress to break down trade barriers
between states and perhaps regulate the
actual shipment or trade in goods and
services across state lines uh it was
not until the 20th century particularly
after the new deal the congress was able
to start using this as a power to
regulate nearly every aspect of human
life that might in some respect affect
the national economy so that i think is
a huge change i think what would really
surprise the framers is how willing
congress has been to give up its own
power so congress has given the
president a lot of power because it's
created administrative agencies with
vaguely defined mandates that therefore
allow the president to use this entire
administrative agency apparatus to
pursue his goals so we've learned that
article 1 of the constitution
establishes the legislative branch of
u.s government which is made up of the
senate and the house of representatives
these two bodies were created to balance
popular power with elite power since
members of the house of representatives
were directly elected by the people
whereas senators were appointed by state
legislatures
although one major change is that
senators are now elected as well what
might really surprise the framers about
congress today is how its power has
evolved over time on one hand as heather
gerkin mentioned the powers of the
president and the supreme court have
grown compared to the powers of congress
but on the other hand as elia solman
points out the framers might be
surprised at just how much of our lives
congress can regulate today
to learn more about article 1 visit the
national constitution center's
interactive constitution and khan
academy's resources on u.s government
and politics